MALE SPEAKER: Good morning.
Welcome to Talks at Google,
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today, it's my great pleasure
to introduce Gershon Ben Keren.
Gershon is here to
discuss this book,
"Krav Maga-- Real
World Solutions
to Real World Violence."
Gershon is head instructor
at Krav Maga Yashir Boston,
which is located in Charlestown.
Krav Maga means "contact
combat" in Hebrew,
and is a generic term
given by the IDF,
or Israeli Defense
Forces, to refer
to the close combat
and fighting programs.
Krav maga yashir refers
to the distinct system
of krav maga that
Gershon teachers.
Yashir in Hebrew means
"direct," and emphasizes
his krav maga system's
no-nonsense approach
to ending violence quickly.
The book describes and
explains the situations
in which various threats
and assaults happen
and the indicators
that precede them.
This gives you a chance to
identify, predict, and avoid
violence before it occurs
so that complete solutions
to violence are described rather
than just physical techniques.
Gershon holds a
third-degree black belt,
was tested and
certified in Israel,
and was inducted into the
Museum of Israeli Martial
Arts in 2011.
Please join me in welcoming
Gershon Ben Keren.
[APPLAUSE]
GERSHON BEN KEREN: It's
always good to have
somebody else introduce
you, because it means
you don't have to
talk about yourself.
It's also quite unique
to have somebody
actually do all the Hebrew
pronunciations correctly.
So there's a good one
there for Johnathan.
I'm not going to talk straight
about what people may think
the book is about, which is
a set of physical techniques
for dealing with
violent situations.
We chose the title of
the book, "Solutions
Rather Than Techniques," because
we wanted to present solutions
in their entirety.
Often, when people start
thinking about self defense,
they get caught up on what
do I do if a knife is placed
in my throat, a
gun to my stomach,
or somebody grabs me
in a particular hold.
What we like to
emphasize is, how
can you prevent those
situations from occurring?
How can you identify
them before they occur?
What are the pre-violence
indicators in a situation?
That doesn't mean
that you're guaranteed
to avoid having to be in
a physical confrontation,
but it means at least
you'll be better prepared.
And hopefully, it means
you'll be able to avoid.
And that's what we
mean by solutions.
And solutions have to
contain modern techniques.
For us, a solution has
to contain information
about personal safety skills.
How can you identify,
predict, and avoid violence
in the first place?
It has to include
skills and understanding
about threat recognition.
Can you actually identify
a threat before it occurs,
and how do you identify it?
It also looks at the
decision making process.
When you're placed in a violent
situation or a potentially
violent situation,
you need to be
able to decide on what to do,
what's your course of action.
An not only that, you have to
be able to make those decisions
under high stress and emotion.
A lot of martial arts may
give off the impression
that the way you
deal with violence
is by adopting a
state of Zen calmness.
My background is in
the security industry.
I don't think in any
situation where I actually
had to deal with
somebody physically,
I was in a state
of Zen calmness.
There are probably
better people than me
who can adopt this state.
I'm not one of them.
And I don't believe that
for the average person
off the street who's
only able to do
a limited amount of
training, that they
will be able to
adopt that state.
So if you think about
how difficult it
might be to make decisions
in everyday life,
couple that with the stress
and emotion and duress
of an imminent, threatening,
and dangerous situation.
So I'd like to start off going
through some of those things--
personal safety, threat
recognition, the decision
making process-- before we get
to the physical techniques.
Because really, if we can
get all of those parts
in place and together,
we might never
need the physical techniques.
And this might seem very
strange for somebody
who's just written a book
which by and large contains
techniques.
So please don't take that as
don't buy the book because I'm
going to give you everything you
need to know and not read it.
Again, we're looking at
solutions in their entirety.
One of the questions
I like to ask people
when we're talking about
personal safety is,
would you ever get into
a car with a stranger?
Just think about
it for one moment.
A lot of people have a
default-- no, I never would.
And yet there are adults
who, despite having
that rule in their head, do
get into cars with strangers.
And this tells us
something about the way
that we often view
personal safety.
We often take a rules-based
approach to personal safety.
We have a list of
do's and don'ts.
And the problem
is, sometimes those
do's and don'ts aren't
applicable to us where we are
in our particular life stage.
Probably the first
piece of safety advice
you were given by
a parent was don't
get into a car with a stranger.
That's my first remembrance
of being told something
that was intended
to keep me safe.
And my parents and
myself at that time
were working off the premise
that that information was
to protect me
whilst I was playing
in the front garden or yard
about a guy pulling up in a car
and asking whether I
wanted to see some puppies
or come with a ride,
et cetera, et cetera.
As an adult, any
predatory individual
who wants to get
me into their car
is probably not
going to be so stupid
as to pull up in
front of me and say,
would you like to
get into a car.
Because they know what I'm
going to say, which is,
no way, mate, just back away.
So I have to understand
that that rule is working
to a model of violence
which isn't really
applicable to where
I am in my life.
So I have to understand that
a predatory individual who's
trying to get an
adult into a car
is going to use very
different means to get them
into that car.
And if we start to understand
how to predatory individuals
operate and exploit
these rules that we build
and our so-called common
sense, we're well on our way to
actually developing a system
of protective measures
that can keep us safe.
So a few examples of where
predatory individuals do
get people into cars and how
they get people into cars-- I'm
just going to explain
so we can start
to get into the
mindset of the way
that these individuals operate.
One sexual predator's
particular MO, modus operandi,
was to troll internet
dating sites.
And he would set up dates,
and everything would be fine.
So he'd set them
up in public places
where the individual in
question, the potential victim,
would feel safe.
He was charming.
He was good looking--
something that we often
don't think about
sexual predators.
But if you think about
it, these individuals
have to be socially
adept or they'll
get caught very, very quickly.
And they're extremely
good at disarming people
through big nice
and being charming.
And over the course of
the meal, everything
would be going fantastic.
And towards the end, he'd say,
this has been a fantastic meal.
I really, really
enjoyed your company.
And it would be a shame if
we ended the evening now.
Tell you what.
I know a bar just across town.
Why don't we go
there, one drink.
I know it's a weekday
night, you might
have work tomorrow,
et cetera, et cetera.
We'll have one drink, and
we'll finish the night there.
So the person is
thinking, this is great.
This is a polite person
who likes, who's in to me,
and who wants to
continue seeing me.
They're not too pushy.
Fine, I'll go.
As they were walking to the
parking lot, the guy would go,
tell you what, why
don't we take my car?
I'll be designated driver.
And this individual has created
a socially awkward situation
where the person's
agreed to go with them.
They seemingly have
taken responsibility--
I'll be designated driver.
This is a responsible
individual.
And now you've got to
come up with a reason
why you're not going
to get into the car.
So predatory
individuals are really
great at creating these socially
awkward situations where really
your only option is to call
them on the safety aspect.
No, I don't want to
get into your car.
I don't feel safe.
And now that seems to go
in total contradiction
with what the planned
drink was, which
was to be in a socially
comfortable situation.
Another sexual predator's MO
was to basically drive around
in remote areas where there
was bad cellphone reception,
and he would rear end female
drivers, like [MAKES NOISE].
The first thing you do when
you're involved in a car crash,
get out of your car.
So again, these
individuals know how
to use common behaviors and
actions in one situation
to get us to basically lower
our personal safety defenses
and just behave on the norm.
In a car crash, I get
out, I inspect the damage.
What would happen?
The car was undriveable,
and he would say,
tell you what, this
is all my fault.
Let me drive you
to the next town.
The person couldn't get
cellphone reception.
They have created what
seems like the only option
available to them, which
is to get in the car.
So when we start looking
at rules that we have,
such as don't into
cars with strangers,
don't let strangers
into our homes,
these predatory individuals
are really, really skilled
at exploiting that rule.
I often get contacted by
newspapers, magazines, asking
for me to give my
top 10 safety tips.
What they're basically
asking me to do
is to give them a
list of 10 rules.
And I know-- and
this is not me being
paranoid-- that the very
individuals this advice
is meant to protect, those
individuals, those predators,
are reading this advice,
and they're formulating ways
to get around one
of those rules.
And this tells us something
about personal safety.
We can't just adopt this
rules-based approach.
Don't walk down a dark alley.
Who hears don't walk
down a dark alley?
So we don't even listen
to the rules that we make.
And we have to understand
that ourselves.
We can also understand how
a rule, such as walking down
a dark alley, might
be detrimental.
And I'm going to give you
a contrived but obvious
situation.
Let's say you're
walking home at night,
and there's a well lit
route where there's maybe
some bars, and some
clubs, and some shops,
and there's a dark alley route.
And as you're walking along
to this well-lit route,
suddenly a bar fight erupts
and bursts out onto the street.
You have a choice now.
Do you walk through
the bar fight,
or do you go down
the dark alley?
It's a contrived
example, but it shows
how a rule that's
meant to keep us safe
can actually put us in danger.
So one of the things
that we advocate
when we're talking
about personal safety
is that we don't take
a rules-based approach.
That what we do is present
information around the way
that predatory individuals
work and operate,
and then say, right,
now it's up to you
to make a dynamic risk
assessment of that situation
that you face.
You understand the components.
You understand how these
individuals operate.
Now form a solution
for that situation.
And the tagline for our system
is, basically, the situation
determines the solution.
So one solution that might be
appropriate in one situation
might not be for another.
So what we try and
do-- and this is
part of what the book
tries to do-- is empower
and educate you so
that you can make
the correct decisions
concerning the threats
you face rather than blindly
follow a set of rules.
And one of the things now
I want to work through
is basically the situational
components of violence
and how predatory
individuals operate.
So we actually have five
situational components.
The first one-- location.
Where does the
assault take place?
Many of us will start
thinking of locations
of dark, deserted places.
That's probably if you
ask most people and say,
where do you think the
majority of muggings occur?
They'll say dark,
deserted places.
The problem with
deserted places is,
by default, they're deserted.
There's no victims
or potential victims.
So we're thinking,
location-- if I
was going to commit a mugging,
I wouldn't want other people
to see it.
Therefore, I would go
to a deserted place.
What a predator is thinking--
where are the victims?
And the larger the
supply, the better.
Because that's going to help
my victim selection process.
So again, we can often rule out
these dark, deserted alleyways.
I'm not saying walk down
dark, deserted alleyways.
They have issues of their own.
But they might not be
those crime high spots
and hot spots that we
naturally think of.
The next situational
component is relationship.
We often think or imagine
that the person who's
going to assault us or cause us
harm is going to be a stranger.
That might not be the case.
It might be somebody we know.
If we're looking at
college campus violence,
most likely because
of that community--
people know each
other-- its going
to be a friend or acquaintance.
And I use friend
in inverted commas.
A motive.
What do they want?
Do they want me?
Do they want to
assault me, abuse me?
Do they want my wallet, my
goods, et cetera, et cetera?
And when we understand
violence, we really
need-- I'll get to the
fourth and fifth points
in a minute-- we need to
understand how a location
and relationship interact.
If you take, let's say,
a crime that happened,
an assault that happened
a few years ago when
a young lady from South Boston
was abducted and murdered--
what we saw in my
studio, because we
run a free women's self
defense program-- is we
were inundated with
women from South Boston.
Because to them-- and I'm
not saying this is wrong--
the key component in that
assault was the location.
South Boston.
So if I live in
South Boston and I'm
a female the fits the same
demographic, then I'm at risk.
And that might be the case.
But let's say that the person
who abducted and murdered
the victim actually had
a relationship with her.
Maybe it was an ex-partner,
an ex-boyfriend.
I'm not saying
this was the case.
Suddenly, the location
doesn't become so important.
It's the relationship
that becomes important.
And if you're trying to make
sense of newspaper and media
reports of violence,
these are really
the first two things
to bear in mind.
Was it the location
that was significant,
or was it the relationship
that the victim
had with their assailant?
So these two kind of
work hand in hand.
After motive, third
parties with you.
Who says you're going to be
alone when you're assaulted?
If you have children and you
spend 23 hours out of the day
with them, chances are,
when you're assaulted,
you're going to have
your kids with you.
Do you have a strategy
and a plan for that,
or is your strategy
and plan solely based
on you being on your own?
And so again, we
have to understand
that violence can be a
little bit more complicated.
And what if the
predatory individual
tries to exploit that, that
they threaten our child
as a means of getting us
to comply and acquiesce
to their demands?
And that does happen.
The other one, state of mind.
What's your mental state?
Are you prepared?
Have you ever even thought about
the likelihood or the chance
that you might be involved
in a violent altercation
or situation?
There's a lot of people who
will put their head in the sand
and say, you know what,
this'll never happen to me.
I don't lead a lifestyle
that basically brings me
into contact with such
individuals and threats.
I would countenance against
that and argue against it.
But by and large, we're
optimistic people.
If you ask-- and these are
basically standard survey
facts-- you make a statement
that the average life
expectancy for an
American is 87 years old
and then ask individuals how old
they'll think they'll live to,
nobody puts 87 or lower.
Everybody is going to
live to 88, 93, 104.
The stats don't apply to us.
Because bad things happen
to other people, not to us.
And that's our default
way of thinking.
So if that is your kind of
way of thinking as you're
confronted by
violence-- everybody
has heard about freezing--
that's what you're going to do.
If you've accepted the
possibility that you might
one day be facing a
violent situation--
I'm not even going to
say the likelihood,
but the possibility-- you'll
be better prepared emotionally
to cope with that.
Professional people who work
in the security industry,
they expect to be
facing violence,
so they're much better mentally
prepared to deal with it.
And there are things that
can affect our state of mind.
For example, alcohol.
If you've been drinking, your
state of mind is affected.
So these are our five
situational components.
And you could almost
come up with matrices
of all the different
variables to create
all the different potential
violent situations
that you could face.
Does that make sense to people?
So we have those
situational components.
To keep things really
straightforward and easy,
I'm going to work
through a predator
profile and methodology where
your relationship with them
is a stranger.
And I'll explain the process
that they operate to.
And the great thing
about understanding
that crime and
violence is a process
is we can recognize that there
are steps and stages in it.
And if there are
steps and stages,
then there are things
that we can identify.
And if we can identify
them, we can disengage them
and move away.
And this is, again, all
part of that approach
to using a solution rather
than just a technique
to deal with a
physical altercation.
Just very quickly
clear the board.
Remember what I
said about location?
This is the first thing that
any predatory individual
is going to do.
They're going to
select a location.
Remember what I said
about deserted places?
They're probably not going
to go to deserted places.
If we take the
example of a mugger,
he's going to want the largest
number of cash rich victims
possible.
So where's he going to go?
He's going to go to shopping
malls, parking lots, transit
stops, where there's
a good supply
of ever-changing
potential victims.
And we call these places as
having crime attractors, what
attracts people to them.
One of the funny things about
being in a crowd, most of us
feel safer when we're
with other people.
That's a default
position that we hold.
Part of the reason
for that is we
start to rely on them
to identify and pick up
threats for us.
And what that ends up
happening is our general sense
of situational awareness
starts to go down and drop.
So one of the things we
might feel safer in a crowd,
because there's other people
who should be looking out
for threats for
us, the problem is,
they're expecting
us to be looking out
for threats for them as well,
and our situational awareness
goes down.
And I'll actually
talk in a minute
about what situational
awareness actually
is from a practical standpoint.
Because a lot of
times when there's
been a spate of
crimes in an area,
the local police will come on--
and I'm not criticizing them--
and they say, people
need to be more aware.
And that's kind of like
saying to me, Gershon,
you need to be better looking.
I totally agree with you.
I don't know how to achieve it.
So the same to me is true
of situational awareness.
It's all very well
saying, you've
got to be situationally aware.
But what does that really mean?
And so I'll start to
explain that in a bit.
So there's crime attractors.
There's also preventers in
a location-- lighting, CCTV.
One of the best preventers in
an area for crimes of violence
and any crime in general is what
we call natural surveillance.
A lot of times when people tell
you about parking your car,
they'll talk about park
in a well-lit area,
which is good advice.
I'm not saying don't.
But even better
than that is park
in an area which enjoys
natural surveillance.
That is where there's a
lot of eyes on your car.
And that normally means
the entrance and exits
of parking lots.
They might be a little
further to walk to,
but you know what, you're
getting the most traffic
past them, the most
eyes on your car.
So if we start
looking at preventers
and we look at something like
natural surveillance, boom,
that's a preventer.
And that's something
we can actually do.
We can park our car in a place
enjoying natural surveillance.
The promoters.
One big promoter is the
number of exit opportunities
for an assailant.
Because they'll be planning
their getaway as well as
the crime itself.
So if they have multiple
routes to go down,
which is why transit stops
are often high mugging areas,
because there's a number
of different routes
that somebody can exit down.
So they select a location--
primarily maximum number
of victims or potential victims.
The next step in the
process is victim selection,
who to actually assault.
And if we start understanding
how predatory individuals see
the world, we can
start to develop ways
where we step off their radar.
There was a famous
study done in 1984
by two New York psychologists,
Grayson and Stein.
Very, very simple experiment.
They set up a video camera
on a New York street,
and they just filmed people.
They then took that
footage and showed it
to prisoners who had
been incarcerated
for violent crimes.
And they said, show me
who the victims are.
There was somewhere
around 87% agreement
amongst all those
different inmates
about who they would select.
And the process never took
them longer than five seconds.
I actually believe that they
identified them immediately
and spent the rest of the time
just making sure to themselves
that that was the person.
And I'll explain a bit about
that as well in the process.
None of them could explain
why they chose a victim.
They would just go, it's them.
I remember once watching
a nature documentary
where it was a pack of
wolves hunting, hunting elk.
And the wolves surrounded this
herd and started the moving.
And suddenly, all the wolves
veered off after one animal.
Now, one elk looks very
much like another elk to me.
I couldn't tell
the difference, why
they had chosen this one animal.
The camera man zoomed in
on one of the hind legs,
and it was slightly hocked.
Something I wouldn't
see, but the wolf saw.
And this is something
we also need
to understand about
predatory individuals-- they
see the world a little
bit differently to us.
So they'll notice things
that we don't notice.
And it will be a
subconscious process.
They'll just go,
that's a victim.
They won't be able to
verbalize or explain why.
It's just that person,
they're a victim.
So what Grayson
and Stein did was
they took the
footage to analysts
who do Laban Movement Analysis,
which is the study of movement.
I think it's around 24 or 28
different component parts.
And they said, these
are the victims,
these are the non-victims.
Show me the differences.
And there were three
things that were picked up
which separated the victims
from the non-victims.
The first one, looking down.
And that seems obvious.
Because if somebody
is not looking,
they're not aware of their
surroundings, which is true.
But looking down also gives
off an emotional state.
If you're depressed,
have low self-worth
and are feeling
down about yourself,
you kind of hang your head.
And if you're
looking for a victim,
you're looking for somebody
who is not going to fight back.
That's basically what
a predatory individual
is looking for-- a person who
is going to acquiesce, not
confront, and not fight back.
And so if somebody has got
that depressed look about them,
they're more likely
to be selected.
Awareness obviously
does come into it,
but your emotional state
and what you give off
and those signals also
identify you as a victim.
The other one was
unnatural stride length.
So when I walk, that's
my natural stride length
for my height.
If I'm walking
with smaller steps,
it's an unnatural stride length.
Let's go back to
emotional state.
Hanging down, shuffling
steps-- giving off
an image of low self-esteem,
less likely to fight back.
The other thing that's
interesting from a self-defense
perspective is, I've heard a
lot of instructors talk about,
you need to present
yourself as a person
they don't want to mess with.
You need to puff out the
chest, you need to walk tall,
and you need to look like you're
somebody not to be messed with.
What that often
ends up doing is you
start to lengthen your
stride length as you
make yourself look bigger.
And it wasn't just people
with shorter stride
length that were selected.
It was people with
longer stride length.
We have a term in
security, which
is the gray man, that you
don't want to be seen.
So you don't want
to be picked up
as a guy who looks like he's
not wanting to be messed with.
At the same time, you
don't want to look
like the person with
low self-esteem.
You want to go unnoticed.
That's your goal.
Be the gray man.
Walk natural stride
length, eye line up.
That's one of the
ways that you're not
going to be picked up.
The third one was
there was a difference
between the movements of
the upper and lower body.
So what do I mean by this?
When you walk, basically,
your arms swing with the legs.
Now, if I walk with the same
arm and same leg movement--
I'm doing it exaggerated--
it's basically
my upper body doesn't
flow with the lower body.
And they refer to it
as a lack of wholeness.
So if we start to
understand those things
and we look at the
physical cues and signals
that we give off to
predatory individuals,
if we walk with
our eye line ahead,
if we have a natural
stride length,
and our upper body moves
with the lower body,
chances are, we'll not be
picked up on the radar.
And it really can be
as simple as that.
People can get really,
really complex about,
this is how you need to make
sure that you're not seen.
It's kind of the easiest
way to be safe is be normal.
Just walk normally.
One of the things
with victim selection
is somebody will be selected.
This is the unfortunate thing.
If there's a mugger in
a shopping mall looking
for victims, he'll
find a victim.
We call it victim displacement.
You just don't
want it to be you.
It will be somebody else.
And this is
sometimes-- people get
confused with
professional safety.
You're not trying
to stop the rapist
from being a rapist or the
mugger from being a mugger.
You're stopping yourself
from being the victim,
preventing yourself.
That's the goal.
The mugger will
still be the mugger.
The rapist will
still be the rapist.
That's for social
change to deal with.
Your personal goal is
to keep yourself safe.
There's other things
around victim selection
as well if we're looking
at physical cues.
There was one sexual
assailant whose particular MO
was to watch women
shopping in supermarkets.
And he'd watch them as they
were pushing the shopping carts.
And let's say I'm
pushing my shopping cart
and somebody else bangs into it,
and I go, I'm terribly sorry.
So I'm apologizing for something
which really wasn't my fault.
The other person
should be apologizing.
This sexual predator would take
this as, this individual so
wanted to avoid any
form of confrontation
that they would take the
blame for something which
wasn't their fault.
That lack of confrontation
or the ability to confront,
that's a big victim signal.
If you look at the way that
you move through a crowd,
are you the person who's
continually moving out
of everybody else's way for
fear of bumping into them,
or are you the person who sets
your own course and everybody
else moves around you?
And again, I'm not
saying in that,
pushing people out of the way.
You can move.
But are you the guy that
keeps your course, or are you
the guy that is apologetic
to everybody else's movement?
So how you move in relation to
other people is also important.
Third, surveillance.
If you're a mugger working
a busy shopping mall
and you've selected
your victim, you're
going to want to make sure
that that victim is actually
victim material.
Because if you make a wrong
choice and confront them
and they confront
you, now you've
just created a whole
scene and an incident.
So again, this predator
is going to want
to make sure about who they have
in their sights is a victim.
I always say in terms of
part of situational awareness
is picking up who has
an interest in you
rather an interest in
what they're doing.
Who's more interested in you
than about what they're doing?
That's a really good cue
that somebody is carrying out
some form of
surveillance on you.
Simple things you can do
to pick up surveillance
when you're walking--
choose a side
of the road where you see
the traffic coming onto you.
You're much more likely
to notice the car that's
done the second swipe because
they're interested in you
than if that car is
going the other way.
So even just choosing the side
of the street that you walk
can be a way of identifying
those people who
have an interest in you.
So now we're getting on to
the actual meat and bones
of practically what our
situational awareness is.
If somebody wants to
attack or assault you,
they have to sync
their movement,
i.e., if I want to
assault any one of you
out there who's listening to me,
I have to get off this podium,
and I need to come
down, and I actually
need to be in physical
proximity to make an assault.
When we talk about
situational awareness
from a practical level,
really what it is, is it's
picking up somebody
else's movement
that's in relation to yours.
That's what it is.
So when somebody is
telling you, you've
got to be situationally
aware and you're wondering,
how do I become
situationally aware--
you need to learn to identify
people's movement as it
relates to you.
And there's four basic types
of synchronization of movement.
The first one, following.
If I directly follow
somebody, I've
tied my movement to theirs.
Has everybody had that feeling
that somebody is behind you?
Yeah?
Is everybody here aware
that you're wearing clothes?
You kind of are now because I
brought your attention to it.
Our subconscious processes
a lot of information,
and it filters out
that which isn't
deemed necessary for
our conscious mind
to process, such
as wearing clothes.
Sound is another one.
I can hear fans going,
the air conditioning,
but until that moment,
we've all blocked it out,
because we are focusing
on this information.
Because that was
what was pertinent
for our conscious
brain to process.
Your fear system runs
in the background.
And it will pick up those
footsteps behind you.
And what it will do is give
you a shot of adrenaline.
You'll get the hairs going
up on the back of you neck.
You'll feel uneasy.
And you go, there's
somebody behind me.
We used to think in
psychology-- and I'll
use the analogy that's commonly
used-- that you saw a bear,
you became afraid,
and then you ran.
What we understand now is a
process-- you see the bear,
you start running.
And because you're
running, you're afraid.
So basically, it's
my physical change
which alerts me to danger,
not me consciously picking up
the footsteps.
So we basically
have what we call
tracking is one means of
synchronizing movement.
Another mean, direct approach.
I could just walk up to you.
That's fairly obvious, though,
if I just walk up to you,
that I've synchronized
my movement.
So what I might do-- if
we come back to location--
is use a crowd to
disguise my approach.
So I'll move through the
crowd approaching you
till I'm really, really close.
And this is the way that
most muggers will work.
And they'll basically
blade their body,
stick the knife to you.
You'll be kind of slightly
turned, and nobody around you
will see what's going on.
And that's how somebody
can do a mugging
in a very crowded place.
And you've got a knife on you.
You're probably not
going to scream.
You're probably
not going to shout.
You'll probably
hand over the money,
and they'll move off
through the crowd.
And that crowd--
also when we look
at what we're talking about
promoters with exit routes--
basically gives a
number of exit routes.
So I have approach.
If I know where you're
going, I can wait for you.
A lot of people use the
remote on their car key fob
to locate their car
in a parking lot.
They come out-- I don't
know where I parked.
Beep beep-- oh, there.
You've just unlocked
your car, which
was the one safe place
in the environment.
If there's a predatory
individual in the vicinity,
there's nothing to stop
them getting in your car.
Another thing people often do
is they'll turn up at a parking
lot, realize they've
got their laptop
and valuables in the
front seat of the car,
know that they shouldn't
be in plain sight,
and so they move them
to the trunk of the car.
If there's a criminal
or criminal element
in that vicinity,
they've seen you do that.
They know that there's something
valuable in your trunk.
They can wait by it, and when
you do beep beep and unlock it,
they can either pull the
trunk-- or move, depending
on the model of the car--
open you driver side,
unlock it from there, and
take what's in the trunk.
So I can synchronize
movement by waiting.
So people know where
I'm going to be.
I'm on my mobile
phone telling people,
I'll meet you at the
Starbucks on Mill Street
in three minutes.
Somebody listening
to that conversation
knows the route that
you're going to take
and can synchronize their
movement and wait for you.
The fourth, interception.
I apologize if my writing
is getting scratchy
as I come to the bottom.
Interception.
I don't have to directly
tie my movement to you.
I can tie it to
where you're going.
And that's a really
difficult form
of synchronization of
movement to identify.
But one of the things I look
for is natural choke points
in movement, such
as road crossings,
and who's going to get there
at the same time as me.
So this is, again,
ways that I train
my situational awareness--
by looking at other people's
movements and identifying
how it relates to me.
The last step in the process
is what we call the interview.
And the interview can be
as really, really simple
as somebody saying, hand
over your wallet to something
much more involved.
Anybody who talks to me,
why are you talking to me?
That's not me being antisocial.
I'm interested.
Why are you showing
interest in me?
People who ask you for
the time-- who here now
doesn't have a mobile phone?
Why does somebody
need to know the time?
Are you the one
guy on the planet
that doesn't have
a mobile phone?
I'm suspicious.
And I'm suspicious of your
synchronization of movement,
that you've intercepted me and
you're asking me for the time.
Something is not right.
Or I'm, at the very least,
within my personal safety
rights to be suspicious of you.
So when we understand that
crime is a process and violence
is a process, we
can go a long way
to actually predicting,
preventing, and avoiding.
We also need to develop
what I was saying
was threat recognition and
decision-making skills.
We generally have two
ways we make decisions.
We have what's called
rationalistic decision
making, which is maybe when
you're looking for the job
here, you had maybe
a few other job
offers that you
were thinking about.
Do I come work for Google?
Do I come work
for somebody else?
And you'll have taken
into consideration
your travel time,
which today was murder.
You'll take into account
the money, the benefits.
Maybe if you have to
move-- do I have to move,
do I have to relocate?
And you're weighing
all of these things
up against the same things of
another job, because you're
looking for the best solution.
The problem is, in
a violent encounter,
one of the things
that will happen
is your assailant will try and
complete this process in record
time so that you don't
have time to respond
to what they're doing.
So part of what we need to
do is try and create time,
but that's another issue.
And so you don't have time
to look for the best solution
and weigh up all
the pros and cons.
If I see somebody coming
towards me, should I run?
Should I shout?
Should I pick up some
forms of improvised weapon?
Should I try and
get some obstacle,
barrier between me and
them, such as a car?
I don't have time to weigh
up all the different costs
and benefits of each option.
What I need to do is something
called naturalistic decision
making, which is
I need to choose
the first effective solution.
That's it.
So if I see somebody coming
towards me, and I go,
will running work?
Yes?
That's what I do.
I don't worry about
all the other solutions
which might be better.
I have an effective solution.
And when you're operating
under stress and duress,
you want to work like that--
first simple solution.
Because your mind's bandwidth
for making these choices
is starting to shrink.
That's one of the
effects of adrenalin.
So if you have an effective
solution, you should take it.
Another thing we
have to understand
when we're confronted
by violence and danger
is, what's our normal
responses to it?
your first response--
remember what
I was saying about
when you're walking
and you picked up somebody was
behind you-- the first thing
you probably did was go into
a sate of denial and went,
oh, I'm being stupid.
The can't be following me.
Maybe they're in a hurry.
Maybe they've just
fallen into step with me.
The first thing we do is
go into a state of denial.
The report on the Twin
Towers after the two planes
hit them showed that
the average evacuation
time after the second plane hit
the second power was somewhere
around six minutes.
And that was people
who knew what
had happened to
one of the towers,
had felt their tower shutter,
and waited six minutes
on average before
they left their desk.
Some people obviously
left sooner.
Some people left later, and
some people never left at all.
That is how strong that
sense of denial is.
Remember how I said
at the beginning
about you tell Americans
average age life
expectancy of
Americans, 87 years old,
how old do you think
you're going to live to?
88, 89, 94.
That's denial.
People often stay in
that state of denial
and don't come out of it.
So the first thing when
you're adrenalized,
you need to accept that
something in that vicinity
has triggered your fear system.
You've got to now work out
whether it's a real threat,
and imagined threat,
et cetera, et cetera,
but having this
kind of knowledge
and understanding of how
predatory individuals operate
gives you a good cue into that.
After denial is deliberation.
What should I do?
Should I run?
Should I confront them?
Should I shout, improvise a
weapon, et cetera, et cetera.
And you go through
that deliberation loop
till you reach a decision,
and after the decision,
you go to act.
That's how we
operate under stress.
So if we can simplify
that deliberation phase,
acknowledge that we
will be in denial,
move out of that quickly,
look for the first effective
solution, and act upon
it, we've basically
cut down all that time we would
have spent processing the best
solution into boom,
we have a solution.
If we go further
than that and start
building pre-built
decision trees,
we can speed it up even further.
So I work through some
really simple heuristics.
Heuristics is just a rule
of thumb, something that's
going to work in the
majority of situations.
And I'll give you
an outline of one
of my very, very
simple decision trees.
If I take a mugging situation--
if somebody comes up to me,
puts a knife to me, and
says, give me your wallet,
I'm going to give
them the wallet.
Why?
In their mind, they
leave with the wallet.
The variable is whether
I get cut or out.
So if they cut me
and take my wallet
or don't cut me
and take my wallet,
I know which is the
best solution for me.
Often, you'll get people
who say, well, I'll
hand over the wallet if
there's like $50 in it.
But if I've got $500, no way.
My question back to that
is, how does your ability
to handle this situation
get any better according
to the money you've
gone in your wallet?
They're not related.
So have that as, you
know what, if somebody
asks for my wallet, my iPod,
my laptop, there you go.
99 times out of 100,
people are going to leave.
If they don't leave, then
I need physical solutions.
And that's what we're starting
to present in the book.
So all of this is leading
up to that physical stuff.
If somebody sticks a
knife to me and says move,
I'm going to act.
Because I know this location
represents my best chance
of survival.
And that's why they want
to take me out of it
and move me to another location.
So I have a really
simple decision tree.
You want something off
me, you can have it.
If you're still here I'll act.
If you want me, I'll act.
It's a really, really
simple decision tree.
And what that's going to mean
is when I have to enact it,
I'm not going to hesitate.
The wallet is going to be out.
You can substitute that wallet.
The majority of muggings
are conducted, basically,
to support a drug habit.
Have $20 in your back pocket.
There you go, mate.
All I've got.
That muggers wants the
situation over ASAP.
You've given them what they
want, enough for the next fix.
They're going to leave
99 times out of 100.
If they stay, now I'm
wondering whether the assault
morphs into something else.
So I like working off really,
really simple decision trees
that get me through that
deliberation process.
And this is what
the book goes into.
It talks about the processes
that different individuals use.
We don't just
present a technique.
We explain how that
situation developed,
how you ended up with a
knife to your stomach.
We also show the
physical technique.
But violence doesn't just happen
like that, as we've learned.
It's a process.
And if I understand
that and the situations
where things are
going to occur, I
have a much better chance
of dealing with them.
Even if it just means
from a mental preparation,
I've spotted this guy
who's intent on causing
me harm, maybe I can do things
such as controlling range,
my actual position
to them, making sure
I've not got my back to a wall.
I can alter the situation.
I have a chance to do things.
If I recognize them long enough
off, maybe I can move away.
If I recognize the
signs and signals
that they're looking for--
eyeline down, shuffling steps--
I'm not going to be pick up on
the radar in the first place.
So we talk about all
of this in the book
and then present the
worst case scenario,
which is the person
has actually managed
to get into a position
to assault you.
And by giving you
that complete scenario
and a complete solution,
what we're hoping
is, yes, that you
learn the techniques,
but also that you
learn what to do
to avoid having to
do the techniques.
I've worked in close
protection, bodyguarding,
and have a saying there which
says, dead clients don't pay.
Your job is basically to
be a bodyguard to yourself.
And when I look at the processes
that we operate and use
in close protection,
a large part of that
is planning-- recognizing the
routes we shouldn't be going
down, recognizing what could
be the potential dangers
and threats, and accepting them,
finding ways to mitigate them.
And then when we're
out with the principal,
the person we're
looking after, we're
looking a long way
down that road.
Because we want to see
a situation develop
in its infancy rather
than as it evolves.
And when we see
that, we move away.
And that should be our
goals for ourselves.
We should basically
be our own bodyguards.
And if I was trying to sum up
anything about what the book is
trying to communicate,
it's that.
And yes, it's full
of techniques.
We film them all
in the locations
in which the types of
assault are likely to happen.
Why?
It helps you visualize.
If you can't get any form
of physical training,
one of the things you
can do is at least
visualize the situation
as it develops.
And that's a great
form of training.
Because one, you're accepting
the possibility and potential
for violence, and also, you're
starting to train yourself
as to what things look like
in their very early stages.
So part of what you can do
is take the principles that
were laid out in the book, look
at the situational components,
change them around, and start
to understand what real world
violence actually looks like.
We've now got time
for questions.
I'm happy to answer on anything
that is security related.
And that can be stuff
from personal safety tips
you've heard about this
is what I should do,
this is how I
should behave, and I
can shed some professional light
on them as to whether they're
valid or maybe a little
bit left of center
right down to physical
stuff you've heard.
So the floor,
guys, is now really
open to you, any
questions you want to ask.
AUDIENCE: Could you talk a
little bit about your decision
tree if somebody
breaks into your house
in the middle of the night?
GERSHON BEN KEREN: Yeah, sure.
OK.
There's different
types of criminals.
And individuals choose a
crime for a set of reasons.
A good example is to
compare a burglar, somebody
who breaks in, to a mugger.
Burglary by and large nets
the person more money.
So it's more profitable
to be a burglar
than it is to be a mugger.
The problem is, if
you're a burglar,
you need to be tapped into
a criminal network who
can change the goods
stolen into cash.
So you need to know a fence.
The other thing is,
that's going to take time.
So you've got to have some
delayed gratification.
The mugger doesn't have that.
He wants that $20 so
he can go to his dealer
and get the next fix.
So you start to understand
when you understand
what motivates people
towards crime a little bit
about their different
characteristics.
A burglar by and large is
going to burgle your house
during the day whilst
you're at work.
That's by and large.
If you're looking at
things to deter burglars,
occupancy is one,
giving the impression
that you're actually home.
Because burglars,
unlike muggers,
don't really want to
interact with you.
They want to go
about their business,
because it takes time
to find everything,
basically unhindered by the
potential presence of somebody
there.
The other one is a dog.
If you don't have a dog, put
a dog bowl out on the porch.
It's victim displacement.
If it's your house or your
neighbor's-- I know this sounds
horrible.
I'm not promoting that you
get your neighbors burgled.
But if you put dog bowl
out, and the burglar,
I have a choice of
two houses, which
one am I naturally
going to go towards?
Burglars are funny individuals
in that they're always
on the lookout for property.
They've got this
subconscious process going.
Interesting stuff
about burglary--
if you live on a
corner house, you're
more likely to be burgled than
if you live on the street.
Remember what I was saying about
promoters, crime promoters,
exit routes, corner house,
multiple exit routes.
That's by the by.
So I understand something
about the burglar's mentality.
So the burglar, by
and large, doesn't
want to interact with you.
They want to steal
the stuff and go.
So let's say you hear
that bump in the night.
You want to give that
burglar time to escape.
Because what you
don't want to do
is put them on the spot
where they feel hemmed in,
pressurized, and now it's going
to be some sort of a hostage
type situation in
your house or they
feel they need to deal
with you as a threat.
Maybe if it's downstairs, get
your partner, call the police.
As they're doing that, stand
at the top of the stairs
or somewhere and just shout
down, we've called the police,
they're going to be
here in five minutes.
Five minutes is enough
time for somebody to go.
If you say something
like, they're
going to be here any minute,
or hear the sirens coming up,
that's when you
might spook them.
And remember what we were
talking about stress and duress
and how your decision-making
ability is affected?
It's the same of the
aggressor and predator.
They will also be adrenalized,
and their decision making
process will be affected.
So again, you've got to
accept the possibility
that they might
do something rash.
But by and large,
most burglars don't
want to interact with you.
They want to steal your
goods, and they want to go.
Another thing to be aware
of, if you have been burgled,
most burglars know that
your insurance takes
a certain amount
of time to clear
and that you'll go out and
buy new goods to replace.
So never go light in terms
of upping your security.
A lot people will go,
I've been burgled,
and it's kind of like, I ought
to do something about it.
I ought to get a
security system.
I ought to do something.
And after a week
or so, it doesn't
seem so immediate a need.
I'll see to it later.
Be aware that your house
is kind of-- they've
broken into it once,
they know how to get in.
And you really want
to be doing a security
assessment of your property.
And that includes basement
doors and garage doors.
They're probably the two
which get overlooked.
I've got this sturdy front door.
But if your basement
door is rotting
and I can kick the lock down,
I'm now in your basement,
and there's no natural
surveillance in your basement.
So I've got all the time in the
world to effectively hack away
at that interior door
to get into your house.
And this goes,
again, what you're
looking for is
natural surveillance.
So if you've got high fences,
bushes, shrubbery, cut it down
so people can actually
see in so there's not
anywhere for somebody to
spend time breaking in.
So that makes sense.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you talked at
length about how
to be aware and
recognize situations
when there's a threat coming.
And you also talked about
what to do when it's already
the point of the knife
being held against you.
So what can you do in
the five or ten seconds
preceding that to avoid it?
Do you run?
What do you do if someone is
following right behind you?
Do you run?
Do you confront them?
Do you change course, et cetera?
GERSHON BEN KEREN:
It's a good question,
and it's probably
that middle ground
which confuses most people.
So you've identified the threat.
It's not yet to you.
What can I do in
that interim phase?
And again, situation
determines the solution,
so not every one of
these is appropriate.
Maybe I want to let the person
know that I've identified them,
that they've lost that
element of surprise.
And that could be as simple as
making eye contact with them.
And that's, again,
depending what I believe
or kind of working
to their motive.
I probably know that in
a crowded shopping mall,
somebody is not
trying to abduct me.
They'll do that more in the
parking lot than in the mall
itself, so it's more likely
be somebody like a mugger.
And if they've lost
that element of surprise
and I can move away,
the chances are
they're going to just
pick another victim.
Because I'm making myself
a harder target for them.
I'm a big fan, where
possible, of getting
barriers and objects between
me and the person I believe
who's a potential assailant.
Parked cars are fantastic.
Parked cars make a
really good barrier.
If you're walking on
the street and you
think somebody's behind
you, move behind it.
Again, if you interrupt
the plan early enough on,
they're probably going to pick
somebody else that's a victim.
And this is why they go
to areas where there's
a large number of
potential victims.
And that's why they're
carrying out surveillance--
to see not only are you
a good potential victim,
but have you picked up on them.
So making distance, putting
objects and barriers
would probably be my short
answer on what to do.
At a higher level, if I really
think it's going to be violent,
I'm looking for an
improvised weapon.
And we talk about this
in the book and the way
the Israeli Defense
Forces teach people
how to improvise and
use the environment.
And it basically involves
categorising objects.
So I look for objects that
are like a stick, objects that
are like a knife, et
cetera, et cetera.
So I can try and make distance.
I can try and put
objects and barriers.
That could be simple as a
table if I'm in a restaurant
or furniture if the assault
is in my house, something
to slow the person's
advance down
and that gives me a
chance to either formulate
another strategy or
basically make my escape,
and then looking for
objects in the environment
that I can use to
protect myself with.
So that, again, would
be my short answer.
But really, if in
that situation you
came up with a solution--
somebody is behind me,
would running work?
There you go.
That's your solution.
You don't really need to
consider any of the others.
And the problem we
often have is our ego
gets in the way of
those solutions,
because we don't want to
look like the guy who's
running away from somebody.
But you know what?
There's only one of me,
and my survival is key.
And if I look a bit
of an idiot, hey,
I've lived my life
looking a bit of an idiot.
I can cope with that.
Does that make sense?
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: How
would the heuristic
change if family
members are present?
That kind of takes away
the running option.
GERSHON BEN KEREN: Absolutely.
And again, this
is something when
we start building
the decision trees.
You might need several
decision trees,
and that's why we have the
situational components,
to start altering
the heuristics.
Kids are a hard one.
A lot of it will
depend on how you've
educated your kid as
to personal safety
and whether you've included
them in on your plan or not.
And this can be a frightening
thing for an adult
to do, to say to a kid, if
we're ever in a situation
where somebody is aggressive
towards me or your dad,
this is what we're going to do.
So you might try and
work out a decision tree
with your kid in mind,
and a lot of that
might be based on your
kid's personality.
And this could be one
where, in terms of fighting,
you really don't want to be
the guy who's seen by your kid
beating seven shades of
snot out of somebody.
That's a consideration as well.
I think this macho idea
that your kid wants
to see your dad defend them,
I think that's a nice idea.
I think when you look at what
the realities of violence are,
you might not want to present
that image to your kid.
So it could be that-- say
you're with your partner
and the kid, that your decision
tree is, first sign of threat,
child gets behind me,
moves away with mom.
So you make yourself
the guy on your own.
So you basically remove
those two third parties
away from the scene
so that you can
work through
heuristics on your own.
It could be in worst
case scenarios--
and again, this is really to
think about whether it's best--
to tell your kid, you know what,
this is not a good situation
for you to be with.
You need to find
somebody else to alert
that there's danger going on.
And one of the things
with educating kids
is you have to see the
world through a kid's eyes
when you do this.
So often, people will say,
go and get a policeman.
Often, kids don't
know the difference
between policemen
and security guards.
They're just basically
in the same uniform.
And also, under stress and
duress, which a kid will be,
they'll be seeing the world in a
much more merged and blurry way
than a distinct way.
And if we look at
the professions which
have yielded some of the
worst child sexual predators,
security guards are one of them.
So I don't want to be saying
to my kid, go find a policeman.
By and large, if you have
to develop a strategy
and you develop your
own heuristics--
I would say these
are my heuristics--
tell your kid to go
and find another woman.
The number of female child
sexual predators is minute.
Most women have some
maternal instinct
and are likely to
look after your kid.
The other things I
would think about
is actually having information
about your child on them.
Because they might not be of
an age where they can remember
phone numbers, the
house where they live,
and all of those things.
So again, your heuristics
have to work for you
according to your
base and skill set.
And they might involve
telling your kid,
because of the situation
and your skill set,
that they need to go and find
somebody to deal with this.
Because they're a liability
with you and likely to get
harmed, and they're better
off in another location.
That's a hard thing to do.
And again, I would always say
when you talk about safety
with your kids, they're often
a lot more mature about it
than we think.
They often have a
better understanding
and are a lot more receptive
and a lot more sensible
surrounding solutions.
We as parents--
I'm a parent-- tend
to think they're going to
get freaked out as soon
as we start talking
about violence.
That hasn't been my experience.
But I think you have to do it
in a mature, non-sensational
fashion and present it more
with, if somebody starts
to behave aggressively towards
me and I tell you to do this,
this is what you do.
And it could be as
simple as things
like putting your
kid in the car.
The other thing
to always consider
is it's the same as the thing
about when you're in a plane--
put your own oxygen
mask on first.
If you're not able to
keep yourself safe,
then there's not a
guarantee that you
can keep your kids safe.
And that's always a
big concern as well--
are you doing something in this
situation which is actually
going to put you in more harm?
To be honest, I would work
off the same simple heuristic.
If somebody wants
money, et cetera,
et cetera, off me, there you go.
If you want me, if you want my
kid, if you want me and my kid,
you know what?
Sorry, I'm going to have to deal
with you physically for that.
If it's a case of
bullying and intimidation,
I think it's a much better
way of basically sucking it
up, putting your ego in
check, letting it happen.
We fight for two
reasons-- ego or survival.
It's a famous quote
from Dr. Gabriel Snyder.
They're the two
reasons you basically
fight-- ego or survival.
So if the situation
you're facing
is one where it's a matter of
ego, be the bigger man on that.
One of the things I always do
when I'm confronting violence
is I decide whether a
situation is premeditated--
that is, somebody has come
to that situation basically
wanting to harm me--
or if it's spontaneous.
Has something I've done
or perceived to have done
caused the person to become
aggressive-- so spill
a drink over them, cut them
off in a parking space.
And in those
situations, I can use
a lot of deescalation skills.
So when I build my really,
really top level decision
tree, is it premeditated,
is it spontaneous?
If it's premeditated,
do they want me?
Do they want my things?
And then I go into
that decision tree.
If it's spontaneous, I
assess their emotional state.
Can I deescalate?
Can I disengage?
So again, we can build the
decision tree a little higher.
With third parties involved,
I would include them
in your heuristics.
Does that makes sense?
Anything else?
OK, guys.
Thank you very, very
much for listening.
I hope you never have to use
the physical skills in the book
and that the personal safety
skills of threat recognition
and the decision-making
skills are
what allows you to identify,
avoid, and protect violence.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]